but say you don't have the money to get
the fashions you see on the red carpet
if you buy a knockoff are you shopping
smart or stealing you'll see her
fashions on the world's most exclusive
runways her famous wrap dress has been
an essential part of every style savvy
woman's wardrobe since it arrived in
1972 Diane von Furstenberg used to be a
German princess and now she's one of the
world's most successful fashion
designers DVF the label and the lady are
totally iconic but as the icon being
ripped off by bargain hunters if you get
rocket shock it that's what I say we're
here to buy rape clothing I'm getting a
mink coat gator boots and a black and
gold suit at santee alley in downtown
Los Angeles shoppers hunt for copies of
their favorite designer fashions yeah
like everything is imitation designer
hair like if you were to go to the mall
everything else is really expensive a
fashion with a budget that's right
Connor illegal is what Diane von
Furstenberg wants to call it or at least
some of it it's the fantasy of every
woman to be a little bit rock star a
little bit rock goddess a bill called
the innovative design protection and
piracy Prevention Act would give
designers a three-year monopoly on new
creations New York Senator Chuck Schumer
introduced the bill and it's being
pushed by the Council of Fashion
Designers of America an industry
organization headed by von Furstenberg
every dress and every top and every pant
that we do really is special and unique
and that's really what single stands for
galina's oval office head designer and
owner of single by Galina Sobolev she
says her clothes have been copied plenty
of times I should be the one really
saying oh my god i want this bill to
pass and yet that's the last thing she
wants it's just a gulp and gateway to
creating tons and tons of unnecessary
litigation the whole point of
intellectual property is to spur
innovation and that according to
supporters is exactly why the fashion
industry needs the bill
without tougher protections they say
designers will have less incentive to
create new looks we create 30 looks per
month everyone and countless other
designers constantly create new looks
even though anything they make could be
copied and sold by someone else it's all
perfectly legal as long as trademarks
aren't copied almost no legal protection
yet the fashion industry explodes with
innovation this bill will create nothing
but new great jobs for all the lawyers
secondly who is the judge who will be
the person that will make the decision
whether the garment is identical or
substantially identical to the design
supposedly protected by this bill judges
usually don't have deep training in
fashion history and so it can be very
difficult to figure out how to convince
the judge judicial system that you are
the first to have ever created a
specific fashion design and nobody else
should have the right to create it for
three years Johanna Blakely of USC's
Norman Lear Center points to the dress
that made von Furstenberg famous and she
claims that she invented this design and
that other designers should not be able
to make it without her consent but most
people who are familiar with fashion
history know that there was another
American designer in the 1940s named
claire mccardell who introduced a very
popular wrap dress the wrap dress has
been around since the the robes since
the bathrobes when would the bathrobes
create it in the Greek and Roman times I
think Greek togas actually qualify and
so I think it's pretty absurd for Diane
von Furstenberg to claim that she owns
this design as a designer every time I
go to create a collection I'm gonna
worry oh my god who is gonna sue me if I
use the sleeve who's gonna sue me if I
create this dress still well off and
Blakely worried that if the bill becomes
law it'd be especially tough on young
designers like a couple we met at santee
alley I feel like that's putting
restraints on something that could be
done so well like I can make my wrap
dress out
different fabric that's completely
different of yours younger designers I
think will be afraid that they're going
to be accused of copying designs that
they have no idea or even made who's to
say you started because when it comes
out so we've all bought from somebody
what's up if this bill was in effect as
we we grew our company we could have
faced probably a millions and millions
of lawsuits and we would have never
actually had a company we would never
had employees and so I think the fashion
houses with deep pockets have the
possibility of trying to use this
legislation to create outrageous
monopolies on designs that probably
already existed at least one other time
before in the history of fashion
Schumer's bill passed the Senate
Judiciary Committee in December but its
current fate is unclear based on the
number of similar proposals introduced
in recent years Congress seems
determined to pass some version of the
bill but why neither Schumer nor von
furstenberg wanted to come on camera to
explain if top-tier designers really are
getting ripped off by bargain hunters if
you look at the customer for a brand
like Marc Jacobs where it personally
cost forty one hundred dollars that's
not the same customer that goes to Canal
Street in New York or goes to santee
alley here in Los Angeles to buy a
knockoff of a Marc Jacobs bag and vinyl
those people would never pay forty one
hundred dollars for a bag that is a
waste of money I would like a car this
will lose hundreds of thousands of jobs
and specifically in California because a
lot of the mess manufacturers are here
and there's a lot of money behind the
bill so it's it's very um it's
disheartening it's very frightening in a
way so should laws make it more
difficult for you to buy copies of your
favorite fashions and what if those laws
cost other people their jobs for reason
TV I'm Ted bellacor
you